go to proxy words aren't proxy wars
supposed to be like
people don't know you're doing a proxy
war or else it's not a proxy war if it's
public it's no longer proxy you're
taking sides so
do you understand what i'm saying when i
see so
so let's just say if u.s you are saying
u.s is doing a proxy we're using ukraine
against russia
u.s israel ukraine
versus when sometimes the they would use
iraq iran they would use these
surrounding countries and
behind closed doors they're supporting
one of the countries but not everybody
knows about it that's the right way to
do proxy not a public proxy war well it
depends how you define a proxy war there
have are proxy wars where a country will
want it be to be done clandestinely uh
so that it will have plausible
deniability uh for example uh iran's
support of the houthis and yemen is
there is a proxy war like that where
they say we're not supporting the
houthis all of this stuff is uh you know
even though they're supplying arms and
uh the north koreans are in there too
helping them with saudi arabia
to scud missiles right against saudi
arabia but that's very well known you're
saying that was supposed to be
clandestine at the time though at the
time well there's still words i feel
like there's a lot of proxy wars that
are out in the open i mean look at
what's going on in gaza israel i mean
palestine iran everyone i mean that's
very well known the vietnam libya
vietnam okay the vietnam war
the soviet union i think the intention
is what you're saying is to yeah i keep
it on the dlc
if you're doing it the way we're doing
it we're not like just supporting
ukraine we're anti-russia
we are anti-like we are ukraine yeah but
so is the entire eu
i totally agree but what i'm saying here
is this is not the proper way of doing a
proxy work well just say
just say
we we are gonna defend these guys
because we're not going to do anything
to work with russia we're not going to
have a conversation with russia to try
to figure out a way to
you know eliminate this worst slow down
the ward or praise play sinner just to
say listen can we figure out a way to
make this work no we don't want to do
that you know he's the next this and you
saw when biden one time we have to get
rid of them and then they slip up and
then they come back and correct them
that was what three four months ago when
he said that i remember he only says
that because that's talked about behind
closed doors you don't say that and have
a slip up if it's not something that's
being talked about people don't have
slip-ups like that so it's no longer
proxy in my opinion i get what you're
saying when the proxy is using somebody
else to go to it it's wide open right
now and putin knows it so if if you're
if you ever thought about negotiating
with putin and saint putin but we're
trying to make this work
and we want to figure out a way
to compromise this is not fair we're
losing you know people are dying
innocent kids are being you know you
don't want that on your you know hands
that that's on you nope that argument is
done but putin's not going to sit down
with you negotiate today because and if
he does everything you say he doesn't
believe anything that comes out of your
mouth am i wrong
i
i think it might be wrong okay okay i
hope because we haven't tried to explore
that
uh you know uh before russia invaded
ukraine and i won't quibble over whether
it's a proxy war or not i mean i i i
think one can argue that it is a proxy
war in the sense that russian and u.s
troops are not directly engaged with
each other and that's what i mean when
i'm talking about a proxy war that's a
good thing and that's what most people
yeah that's a that's a good thing uh you
know uh but i i i i also agree with you
that certainly from the russian
perspective and uh from the nato
perspective in terms of what we're
saying publicly and all the rest our
objective does seem to be
you know to try to achieve regime change
in russia through ukraine i mean
senator lindsey graham for example you
know has called
uh you know for uh providing no exit for
russia out of this and that we're going
to stay in this thing to the end and
there are some analysts expecting
extraordinary results uh you know from
this that uh for example the putin could
fall from power that we could force the
russians to give up all their tactical
nuclear weapons uh that russia will have
to return all of the conquered
territories uh uh fr from ukraine which
i think is
unrealistic and extremely dangerous to
expect those outcomes and this from
people who before the invasion happened
was expecting russia to run over ukraine
in 72 hours you know when your
intelligence is so wrong you know that
ought to give you pause about whether
you should be involved in the war when
your intelligence is so wrong
and i you know because i i not i i think
it's wrong again having these very
unrealistic expectations but um
the russians offered a peace treaty a
six-point peace treaty before they
invaded ukraine
and uh i i have argued uh
i think
i think we could uh
win the new cold war in ukraine by
negotiating a peace with russia
offering to negotiate peace with are we
doing that they no we're not why are we
not doing that
because the uh
the biden administration
claims they did but they didn't
seriously try to negotiate that piece
okay
uh you know uh yeah i think that because
the uh the biden administration is uh
uh
listening to people who think that they
can win
uh the new cold war against russia by
defeating
russia
i think they have a very short sight
things are going well right now in
ukraine and they want to keep pumping
arms in there to make things as bad for
the russians as possible
uh you know and and hope that maybe some
of these really
uh
extraordinary developments that they're
hoping for that might be putin will fall
from power uh or at least we'll give
russia such a bloody nose in ukraine
that the chinese will be deterred from
trying to invade taiwan because the same
thing will happen to them and uh and uh
and that uh and that if we can use
ukraine the proxy of ukraine to really
inflict a serious defeat on the russians
that it'll keep the russians pacified
and in their cage you know for years to
come
and therefore
this is uh it's worth doing this and
it's worth taking these risks to do that
and we're not really taking risks anyway
because everyone knows a nuclear war
cannot be won and and uh and must never
be fought and so putin's nuclear threats
are not going to be uh are not are not
going to be acted upon and i think that
that's it's a very shallow
uh
dangerous
uh policy that we're following that
assumes that russia will not resort to
nuclear or emp or cyber warfare on a
large scale against nato europe or
against the united states itself
in order to prevail it's also based on
the premise that
that russia is
really on the ropes in a in a in a
deeply serious way and that might not be
true we don't know that that is true at
all i mean russia has been fighting this
war with one
hand you know with its left arm and its
right arm tied behind its back you know
they've only committed uh really a
relatively small fraction of their
forces despite what's being said in the
newspapers and all the rest you know
they have now fully mobilized to fight
fight this war even john bolton who
wants us to do what the biden
administration is doing and wants to
have this war a big war against russia
even john bolton is talking about well
you know we need to be prepared to fight
a war against russia he's calling the 30
to 100 years war
you know because this is uh because
putin and not just putin but he believes
the russian elites that this isn't just
putin's war but that the russian elites
who want to restore the russian empire
that this is a maine
that they consider this essential you
know to their geo long-term geopolitical
survival to reconstitute the old ussr
including taking over ukraine and that
they are going to be willing to fight 30
to 100 years you know
in ukraine in order to achieve that
objective so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you